>> WE REPORTED EARLIER TRAGIC
NEWS TONIGHT LISA MARIE PRESLEY
HAS PASSED AWAY AT THE YOUNG AG
OF 54 YEARS OF AGE.
COHOST GERALDO RIVERA REACTION.
I LOOK AT HER DAD, ONE OF THEM
MOST GIFTED AND TALENTED
UNBELIEVABLE PERFORMERS OF ALL
TIME, IT HAD TO BE VERY HARD FO
HER GROWING UP IN HIS SHADOW.
WE DON'T KNOW I GUESS CARDIAC
ARREST IS THE CAUSE OF DEATH.
WAY TOO YOUNG FOR MY FEELINGS.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> IT'S AWFUL.
ICE IN MY CONDOLENCES TO
PRISCILLA, HER MOM.
IT IS A TERRIBLE TRAGEDY.
THE AWFUL GUT WRENCHING THING I
IT WAS ON TUESDAY NIGHT AT THE
GOLDEN GLOBES THAT SHE WAS WITH
HER MOM AND THEY WERE
CELEBRATING AUSTIN BUTLER THE
GUY WHO PLAYED ELVIS AT THE
BIOPIC.
THEY WERE ALIVE AND VIBRANT AND
OPENING NIGHT AND EXCITEMENT AN
ALL THE REST OF IT.
A COUPLE OF DAYS LATER SHE IS
DEAD.
IT'S STAGGERING UNEXPECTED.
LISA MARIE HAD IT WRITTEN
EXTENSIVELY ABOUT HER PROBLEMS
WITH ADDICTION.
WILL WITHHOLD JUDGMENT UNTIL WE
HEAR THE FACTS OF FROM THE
EXAMINER.
IT IS AWFUL.
HERE'S A LITTLE GIRL WHO WAS
BORN INTO A HURRICANE.
SHE LATER MARRIED SHE'S THE
DAUGHTER OF THE KING OF OTTER
LOCKABLE SHE LATER MARRIES
MICHAEL JACKSON THE KING OF POP.
AT THE KING OF POP THE KING OF
ROCK 'N' ROLL THERE'S LISA MARI
TRYING TO FIND HER WAY IN THE
WORLD HER OWN SON KILLED HIMSEL
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
IT'S TRAGEDY.
>> I FEEL FOR THIS FAMILY ELVIS
WAS A MAGNIFICENT PERFORMER.
I LOVED HIS MUSIC.
I WAS HONORED TO MEET HIM A
COUPLE OF TIMES.
>> HE WAS SO SPECIAL AND HE
LOVED HER.
HE NAMED AIRPLANE LISA MARIE HE
FLEW HER NEAR IN TIMES TELLS TH
STORY HE FLEW HER UP TO IDAHO
BECAUSE SHE HAD NEVER SEEN SNOW
BEFORE HE LOVED HER AND THAT
THIS IS JUST AWFUL.
SHE LATER MARRIED IN THE CAGE
THE ACTOR.
TERRIBLE.
I FEEL FOR THIS FAMILY AND
PRISCILLA MY THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS ARE WITH YOU